when you were four years old you were
diagnosed with Vitiligo what do you
remember most about that particular
moment
I was four so I don't remember yeah but
um I I actually only remember it through
the memories of my family so I just
remember like my grandmother was telling
me that you know my mom would be really
worried and show her like the new spots
coming up on my back and she would
always say to her like you can't do that
you can't like lift up her back and show
me anything because it makes her feel
different and so
um those type of learnings I've gotten
from my my grandmother I definitely want
to bring forward to when I eventually
have kids and making sure that they feel
special but not different because like I
mean we are all are different but not
feeling
um
outside of anyone else yeah and I know
that high school was difficult to
navigate was there a specific moment
where you knew okay I gotta be
homeschooled I'm sick of this
um I was never homeschooled you know no
no I thought it was you went through
experiences in school no I went to I
went to Adult School actually from
Toronto so you know I went to
um peel alternative oh okay yeah what's
alternative school first and then I um I
ended up going to adult school and I did
really really well in adult school yeah
because I mean it was like all adults
and it was just like learning and
actually absorbing knowledge so I
realized that like I really was into
um psychology and like so many different
things that I didn't get to learn in
high school
um but then when my modeling careers
started taking off I had to leave school
again so
um yeah I always thought she left school
that's what I was told no I kind of did
yeah because when I when I went to
Alternative School it gives you the
freedom of like not going if you don't
want to go so like I only had to go for
like specific classes yeah but I didn't
have to go the whole day but now when I
get a job job and I'm making money yeah
at a little call center in downtown and
my job is in Brampton and I gotta pick
and decide I was choosing the money and
I regret that because that was so not
smart I wasn't playing for the future I
was only living for like today's
satisfaction that was horrible but um
but I'm happy that I kind of got back on
the right track and I always knew that
education was important so even when I
stopped going to school and I was
traveling a lot for my job I would still
have like a French tutor I still went
back to my old ballet teacher and I was
just wanting to do things that were
going to like work my brain and like
help me
um not lose you know the mental side of
things even though I was doing modeling
yeah I know that you wanted to be a
ballerina
yeah entertainment journalist yeah when
did modeling get on the radar
um
so you do you know um Shannon boudram
it sounds familiar Shan Budram um she's
also from Toronto but she lives out here
oh yes yes I do yes yeah so she's like a
big sister to me I met her when I was
like 16 years old she saw me on Facebook
and was like you're so beautiful I had
this hotline I want you to um rock it
for me I'll come and I'll shoot you and
I was like okay cool she did a whole
interview with me it was really cute and
she was like you are so beautiful you
could be on the cover of Vogue Harper's
bizarre at this time I didn't even know
what Harper's bizarre was
and I was just like okay wow thank you
like I appreciate it and um and that was
kind of what sparked the idea for me so
anytime I had things where I needed to
film something as like a
like trying out for things I would reach
out to her my big sister and be like can
you help me film this I'm not very tech
savvy and
um yeah she just kind of saw that in me
but then also helped me as well yeah I
knew I know that you grew up in a tough
neighborhood
which you're now in a tough industry so
what is a lesson you learned from the
way you grew up that you applied to
every day doing this job
um
I think I would say
not taking those as an answer you know
like
I think
even growing up like and he knows that I
I would hear growing up I think I took
them really hard when I was younger
um but as an adult now I think hearing
those no's and realizing that even
though I heard those notes and I may
have taken them hard before yeah I got
past them I got through them I grew from
them I learned from them and so now as
an adult when you are you know not
getting the things that you want and
things aren't going the way that you
want it's so much easier to be like you
know what I made it this far and I'm
very happy and proud of myself so
whatever God sets forward for me is for
me yeah you've turned a lot of no's into
yes and I know when I look at your
career just your history and your career
it's been a lot of knows that you turn
into yeses so you are like the
manifestation of that I like kudos to
you America's Next Top Model and then
you made history walking Victoria's
Secret and I understand like the year
prior it was a no yeah and then you made
history right like right another no
exactly and that was funny too because I
actually went back to my friends and
told them that I didn't get it yeah and
they were like aren't you so upset like
you should be walking that they're
missing out on having you walk and I was
like no like I just need to work harder
next year I need to like go hard in the
gym I need to you know whatever I need
to do yeah I need to try to try it again
like it's not any exception for me if
anything it was harder for me in this
career you know so like sometimes it's
funny to me now that I've actually
created a lane for myself in this
industry that there was never a lane set
forth for me people will be like she's
only a model because her skin and I'm
like well it was actually the opposite I
was never supposed to be a model because
of my skin so I've actually fought
against that but
um
but it's beautiful to me now that like
people can even have the idea that oh
she's I'm like Okay cool so that means
that you must think that my skin is
beautiful now which nobody thought
before so you know it's double-edged
sword but there's Beauty in it yeah
you're a coming up story so many
different things which
being discovered on social media
obviously America's Next Top Model
Victoria's Secret all those things pale
in comparison to the career that you
built for yourself now but what is one
thing that you look back on your come up
story that you're the most proud of
the most proud of yeah
um I think being able to be independent
is something that makes me very proud
especially as like my dad has always
been someone that I look up to and like
how hard he works and how well he takes
care of his kids and all that I've
always wanted to be like that type of
Hustler that type of worker and
um I think
seeing my dad in me makes me the most
proud
oh
he's gonna be so he's gonna love that oh
he's gonna love this
what would you say is your biggest Pinch
Me moment my biggest Pinch Me moment
yeah
um I think my biggest Pinch Me moment
I have a lot I have a lot to do this I
think one big one for me that happens
like
here and there is like any time I'm
watching a show
and like I'm walking the same show as
Naomi Campbell yes like
is kind of a full gag like what whoever
knew I would be you know what I mean
like walking behind the footsteps of
you know someone who knocked down so
many doors for me to be able to do what
I'm doing yes it's insane yeah and then
now you're knocking down doors for other
people like I saw the video of you and
April star
when I tell you I cry I did too
she's so gorgeous she is so gorgeous
what would it have been like for you as
a young Winnie to have Winnie
um like if you had you when you were a
little girl yeah you know I I'm also
like the big sister as well so like I
always wanted a big sister and so
I think to be able to have someone like
me someone just to look up to or someone
to like look to for
um advice or anything would have been so
incredible and I think it's such an
honor that by just being myself and like
you know
choosing to be who I am yeah and not
change anything for anyone
that being inspiring to people is an
honor like you know
I know you don't believe in Role Models
you just believe in inspiring one
another
is there anybody that you are inspired
by specifically
so many people yeah so when he was your
person yeah yeah no I mean so many
people I don't I think that people kind
of get that misconstrued so that I don't
believe in Role Models I believe like
you said like in people being
inspiration to people but I don't like
putting people on a pedestal because
we're all human and when you do that
whole you know pedestal thing people
can't make mistakes and I hate that
um
and you can also look at someone's
whole life of good and then one moment
of bad and especially with today's like
cancel culture and all that type of
stuff like I really
like to untangle that whole idea of Role
Models yeah so
um I definitely do have people that
inspire me so many people my grandmother
my mom my dad
um my um
my sister even inspires me she's like my
sisters are so themselves you know
they're my little sisters and even when
I look at them I'm like oh my gosh I
love I remember growing up and one of my
sisters lived with me and she um
she has learned so much for me she's
like a little me but I always said when
she was little I'm like oh I just want
her to be like the cool girl in school
all that and I look at her now I'm like
she's like leading the pack of her
friends so I'm like
it's so cute
I'm so proud so yeah like I I pull
inspiration from so many places so many
people